do we have an unhelpful advice with you
you know what this is at the end no tell
me every show we have an email and
people with problems and we give them
either good guys or bad advice
this is this is kind of I'm not it's not
some of it's like we do did we do advice
on our podcast you guys can you guys do
the people phone in with their secrets
yeah I love that I had I was very
envious and I was like why didn't I
think of that you guys worked so good on
it you were so funny if you listen to
that podcast guys if you love these two
you look gonna love them on our podcast
it could I see your you being on this
was so insightful for me
I talked about things I never talked
about well III really because I I get in
the rhythm of talking about the same
[ __ ] and it's like I learned a lot
from you and um I truly honestly I don't
understand why I know you're busy and
stuff but we should be more better
friends I agree and I didn't get that
before we go into unhelpful advice I
didn't get to thank you for what a kind
intro you had I mean there's nothing
kinder than a comedian saying I don't
talk [ __ ] about this person behind their
back yeah but the feeling is is and
always has been so mutual I love you I
love you man yeah go ahead I'm hopeful
advice with Bobby
kalila high school student living in
Northeast Iowa for the past few months I
have been met with the problem I think
my girlfriend's dad wants to kill me
we've been dating eight months and I'm
madly in love but her father does not
let me be with her because he does not
trust me
we have only kissed around five times
and have not even hooked up recently she
says she wants to take a break from me
and her dad wants her to break up with
me if she doesn't he will beat her what
should I do
yes I'm a huge kid 210 pounds of mostly
muscle it can bench over a hundred
pounds over my own weight I am much
larger than her father
how old is he no age but high school
beat the [ __ ] I love the part at the end
he's just like just FYI damn in a
picture I could not
in a hot second my thing is this is that
and if we've talked about this before
but it's your first high school I know
it's like nothing it's not worth the
beatdown it's not worth any of it it's
that rusty dude I'm telling you right
now if I would have married the small
selection of women that were at my high
school I probably would have had a
miserable life if I would have married
John Linn I would have been great I
didn't I didn't the other boys
Sergio with the BMX no he eventually
lost his mind
but John yeah Google I honestly I still
look at his Instagram and I I imagine
I'm like you know what that would not
have been such a bad life what a reveal
this was at the very end of the ha no I
wait could do we want to process this so
keep going well I was just thinking that
the again no one's impressed with how
much you can bench if you say how much
you can bench if you did get sexual with
this girl it would be uneventful for her
because no one oh man since I'm a second
bench has ever been a good level but but
in he said he said something very
pivotal which is because my first bit of
advice is gonna be that you should just
walk up to the dad and make the V the
like the [ __ ] eating you know you
always break up the tension with a joke
or whatever you know she said now if to
be serious she said she he said she
recently did asked for some space which
means like so this girl let's pretend
you guys really are in love and you have
two different competing poles right the
love and then this like weird abusive
father situation and the this woman this
girl has made a choice which dynamics
she's interested in playing she's
decided I'm gonna go with the [ __ ] up
because it's very difficult to break
family patterns I'm gonna go towards the
abusive dad situation yeah so your
answer has already been given to you
she's decided to side with the abusive
dad your relationship no that's even
that we don't know what the dad is
really
right right what he's like we don't know
circumstances like I can't it does sound
fishy yeah I can't date you anymore or
my dad will beat me today pissed like
four times five koala high five time
kiss yeah that still sounds charitable
don't you remember I told it's either I
don't like you I never liked you or my
dad beats me yeah she just chose the
third excuse I used to just [ __ ] virgin
boys is that true right yeah you did I
wouldn't I wouldn't [ __ ] virgin boys no
no I wouldn't I would if I